per a tutti e sono benedetta bruzziches
ho 28 anni
nasco vivo e lavoro a caprarola
caprarola questo piccolo paesino in
provincia di viterbo sui monti cimini
che è stato la mia più grande scuola
nonostante io abbia frequentato lo ied e
quindi abbia poi avuto modo di avere una
preparazione h dal punto di vista
professionale nell'ambito della moda che
di quello di cui mi occupo moda e in
particolare o una un'azienda che in
realtà non è un'azienda perché è che è
diventata una filosofia che è una
filosofia che che vede nell'artigianato
e quindi nella riscoperta di quello che
di quelli che sono i valori del made in
italy
il suo il suo cuore però in realtà io
vorrei approfondire un po che cosa sono
i valori del made in italy in realtà
cioè che cosa è questo made in italy
perché forse anche in italia si è
parlato moltissimo di prodotto
ora in realtà quello che io faccio a
litro della mia azienda che non siamo
neanche borse perché in realtà andare un
po a ridurre quello che quello che
effettivamente facciamo io le mie lo
vediamo neanche borse li chiamo
talismani sono talismani perché nascono
per un motivo e nascono in un modo e in
un mondo che poi alla fine è quello che
noi comunichiamo al mondo è il motivo
per cui le borse vengono comprate allora
come nascono queste borse nascono a
caprarola da me disegnate da me e dal
mio gruppo di dai ragazzi che lavorano
con me e non sono i miei dipendenti sono
i miei artigianautica partigiana ti
credo che sia una parola che non ha
neanche bisogno di essere raccontata
perché esalta sono ragazzi agostino un
mio fratello 20 26 anni laureando
all'università di beauty
di firenze ha smesso di lavorare perché
di fare l'università perché per venire a
lavorare con me e ha imparato il lavoro
dell'artigiano vuol dire che ha parlato
a cucire a tagliare insieme a lui
massimo 25 anni ex lavorava in una in un
azienda di mobili e insieme a lui
filippo uno dei credo più grandi
conoscitori dell'artista murakami
laureato in beni culturali
angelina laureata in a un avvocato che
invece ha deciso di occuparsi di quella
che è la comunicazione e la
distribuzione della collezione eco tutti
questi ragazzi si sono messi insieme con
il preciso intento di recuperare quelle
che sono di quello di recuperare quelle
che sono le nostre tradizioni
artigianali per cui partendo da
caprarola e qui vorrei aprire un piccolo
per farvi capire un po per cos'è la
caprarola capraro a caprarola o comunque
nel viterbese venivano prodotte le più
incredibili produce venivano fatte le
più incredibili produzioni di maglieria
fatto a mano
allora la maniera fatto a mano non può
essere prodotto in maniera industriale
deve essere perfetta fatta a mano e
veniva fatta dalle signore all'interno
delle case e quindi si riunivano tutti
questi gruppi di donne che facevano
queste lavorazioni fatte a mano in casa
per armani per prada per voi quando
queste aziende hanno deciso di spostare
la produzione dall'italia all'estero
che cosa hanno perso queste signore
hanno perso non soltanto la possibilità
di lavorare di insegnare questo lavoro
alle proprie figlie e quindi di farla è
crescere questa artigianalità hanno
perso soprattutto la possibilità di
stare insieme e attraverso questo tipo
di condivisione che cresce l'italia
è questo il made in italy di cui io
parlo è questa la filosofia che è
diventata la mia azienda
allora quelli che vedete qui sono tutti
per esempio è loro
lui lavorava
alla rai faceva il montatore di film
insieme a sua moglie adesso ho imparato
a fare le borse intrecciandole sulle
forme di legno una tecnica antichissima
gatti 20 si sarebbe persa che cosa
avendo io amo una delle mie borse più
vendute
si chiama cabaret perché non sa cosa sia
un cabaret
glielo dico io il cabaret e non è un
pacchetto di pasticcini è un preciso
momento della nostra vita che noi
raccontiamo al mondo attraverso questa
collezione perché rappresenta la gioia
della domenica mattina quando dopo la
mesta mio padre come vostro padre come
vostro fratello l'accompagnava di
pasticceria a comprare il cabaret di
pasticcini per cui in realtà secondo me
che cosa che cosa ci porterà lontano
questo racconto il racconto di un
prodotto che non è un prodotto di una
borsa che nascerebbe essere un per
essere un talismano perché per me la
moda e comunicazione personale e può
essere magari anche quella cosa che ci
permette di vivere un'atmosfera o di
vivere una suggestione che cosa indosso
io oggi la mia frangetta tagliata male
che già indicativa di quello che sono
questo vestito che è nato da un baratto
di una delle mie borse con un altro tipo
di lavorazione artigianale tutto tutto
in realtà si può trasformare il lavoro
io credo che l'artigianato sia una
grandissima opportunità innanzitutto
perché non presuppone un grandissimo
investimento iniziale e poi perché io
credo che dal momento in cui sono
scomparsi i laboratori artigianali della
nostra città che cosa è successo
io io non lo so mi sono trovata a
riflettere che cosa è successo dal
momento in cui uno perso il contatto con
quello che succede all'interno di un
lavoratore artigianale io ho perso la
possibilità di ricordare che attraverso
l'utilizzo di queste cose che abbiamo
attaccate alle braccia si possa si può
realizzare quello che abbiamo in testa
per cui secondo me
che cosa serve qui in italia visto che
io sono assolutamente convinta del fatto
che abbiamo già qui tutte le possibilità
per farlo essere un paese incredibile
perché ciò è un paese incredibile
abbiamo bisogno di tornare a credere che
quello che noi immaginiamo quello che
noi pensiamo si può realizzare
attraverso le mani e questo credo che
sia il grandissimo insegnamento che ci
dà all artigianato e questo credo che
sia anche è doveroso che dal punto di
vista scolastico si insegni a desiderare
ea sognare in grande
perché che cosa significa sognare in
grande significa per una ragazzina di
caprarola a cui la nonna diceva ma dove
vai in giro vestita così coi fiori in
testa
non c'è bisogno che fa l'università
potresti andare a lavorare il
supermercato significa mettere insieme
un gruppo di ragazzi che lavora insieme
in maniera bella in maniera armoniosa e
e creare un'azienda che negli ultimi tre
anni non soltanto produce le borse più
belle e incredibili del mondo che quando
le aprì ti ricordano che devi sognare in
grande fattura comunque dà la
possibilità a 10 20 50 persone di
lavorare lavorare insieme lavorare in
comunione e racconta album ed al mondo
una prospettiva di cosa è possibile fare
ecco io vorrei raccontare che io credo
che dovremmo credo che quello che vorrei
fare quello che mi propongo di fare è
raccontare il valore delle cose allora
questo per me è un momento molto
difficile lo sapete perché fra un paio
di settimane si presenta la nuova
collezione e e quindi stiamo lavorando
tantissimo tra collezioni o produzioni
che cosa succede i miei ragazzi i
ragazzi insieme a noi lavoriamo tutto il
giorno tutta la settimana ci fermiamo un
giorno a settimana la domenica
una delle ultime cinque domande alle
ultime 5 domenica
questa parte io comunque vado il
laboratorio a lavorare e il laboratorio
succede una di quelle cose che succedono
nelle favole o nelle pubblicità della
mulino bianco che la notte la notte
arrivano i le fasi di qualcosa e fanno i
biscotti oppure quando il pane ecco la
stessa cosa succede all'interno il mio
laboratorio perché se niente di parenti
arrivano tutti i miei zii che anche loro
hanno imparato a fare questo tipo di
valore
un modo quindi mandare un prodotto che
non ha in mano si ritiene portante della
nostra cultura del fare cominciare
facciamo perché per le cose succedono
solo di fare la pace
prima di finire in e musicista piene
era o ci mettiamo noi noi con cui colpa
telecom in una strada del braccio che
tipo di una grandissima voglia di fare
finalmente fare perché il mondo
facciamo che le cose non si avverano
sogni si avverano invariato mariano
ghiaccio di non
riduciamo a sognare